بجنبي قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
بلاده مصممه على اشتفاف حزب العمال
الكردستاني من جذوره ووصف اردوغان الحسبه
بتنظيم الارهابي معتبره انه يشكل تهديدا
على تركيا وسوريا والعراق كما دعا لانهاء
وصفها بلعبه دعم حزب العمال لكردستاني
وامتداداته التي تتخفى تحت ستار مكافحه
تنظيم الدوله
اتراك في الاسبوع الماضي بينهم ثلاثه
اطفال وذلك في شارع الاستقلال في اسطنبول
ومن بعده في ناحيه كركميش في تركيا
مسؤوليته دماء هؤلاء ضحايا تقع على هذه
المنظمه الانفصاليه والدول التي تدعمها
بالسلاح والعتاد باسم محاربه داعش التي من
الواضح انها مزروعه في منطقتنا تركيا التي
حاربت تنظيم الدوله على الارض وجهها لوجه
وهزمته لن تقبل بتبريره تنظيم حزب العمال
الارهابي ليس تحديدا لوحده التراب التركي
بل انه تهديد لوحده التراب السوري
والعراقي ايضا ونحن مصممون عليه المنظمه
الارهابيه من جذورها